Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number 21, price action. Price action is
the second weapon in our armory within the
gatekeeping process. So again, here we're
trying to cleanse our ideas. And our ideas
at this stage are still just ideas.
And when we're monitoring price action, we
do this in conjunction with our technical
analysis. And we do this on our watch
list. And the easiest way to actually
teach you this is to show you by doing. So
what we're going to do is just actually go
straight to the computer screen. And I'm
going to show you a watch list with many
spread trades on and trades in currencies
and commodities.
And we're going to go through this watch
list. And we're going to show you the
processes that you go through each week in
order to generate good trades. So let's go
over to the screen. And I'm going to see
you at the end of this video with a full
rundown and summary of the gatekeeping
process.
Thank you.
Okay, so welcome back to the computer
screen.
What we're going to be looking at here is
the gatekeeping process.
And the processes that you go through for
monitoring price action and technicals.
And what we're going to be looking at is a
watch list.
So we're going to be looking at primarily
this spreadsheet.
Called the watch list example.
And the other spreadsheet.
Which is called watch list spreads.
Watch list spreads is basically just a
template of watch list example.
And we're also going to be just going
online and getting publicly available
data.
And we're going to be going through
processes on this watch list that you
would go through on a weekly basis when
you're starting out.
So let's go through this spreadsheet.
And there's quite a few concepts that you
have to pick up here.
Firstly, when you look at this watch list,
you'll see lots of ideas on the watch
list.
What you need to understand here is that
this is the first thing really, is that
when you're running a portfolio, you have
to look at your gross exposure that you
actually want in your portfolio.
And then you have to look at your
portfolio, and then you have to create a
watch list to service that gross exposure.
So when we look at this example, this
example has 24 spread trades on the watch
list within stocks.
And we also have forex and commodities, so
energy, metals, and food.
Now, if we're just staying within stocks,
we have 24 spread trades here.
Now, what you're looking at when you're
seeing this spreadsheet is actually a real
example of somebody that's taken this
course.
They've gone through the course and then
created their own watch list, and eight
weeks later, they're now running their
watch list and updating it every week.
And when you look at it, the first thing
that you should notice is that they have
24 ideas,
and also they have six situations that
have actually been taken off the watch
list.
And in fact, when you look at the
accompanying text, these spread trades
here have actually become real positions
in the portfolio.
Now, what do we mean by working backwards
from your gross exposure?
Well, if, for example, you want to have a
portfolio of $240,000 gross exposure,
which this person actually has,
then to service that portfolio, you're
going to need quite a lot of ideas.
So, if we're working backwards from
$240,000, if this person has a
self-imposed position limit of $20,000,
so if they're doing a spread trade $20,000
long and $20,000 short,
then that just means that they're going to
have 12 positions in their portfolio, or
six spread trades.
So, that's going to equal $240,000 gross
exposure.
So, if we're working backwards from that,
and we're going to be creating a watch
list that actually services our portfolio
well,
then it's pretty obvious that we can't
have just six spread trade ideas.
Because all that happens is, when you're
running your real portfolio,
we're admitting to ourselves that clearly
we're not superheroes.
We're going to get trades wrong.
So, at any one point in time, you're going
to have trades that are winning and trades
that are losing.
And if you don't have a well-maintained,
updated, and fresh portfolio,
as in lots of new ideas coming onto the
watch list,
then that watch list can't service your
portfolio with good trades to replace
losing trades.
So, what you're trying to do here when
you're running your watch list is two
things.
Firstly, you're trying to stop yourself
making bad trades.
So, your ideas go on your watch list and
you're stopping yourself from firstly
doing bad trades
and also entering potentially good trades
at the wrong time.
That's the first thing.
We'll come back to that a little bit later
when we look at a specific example.
But secondly, what you're trying to do is
you're trying to spoil yourself with good
ideas and good trades.
So, if we just look at the numbers for a
second, we've got 24 trades, or 24 ideas,
sorry,
at this stage on the watch list.
And six have actually been taken off.
And they've become real positions.
So, that's going to leave 18 ideas on the
watch list.
Which means, if they've got, if this
trader has six spread trades, so 12
positions,
they have six spread trades in their
portfolio,
it means they've got three times as many
ideas on their watch list as they do live
positions
in their real portfolio.
And as a general rule of thumb, what you
should really be doing is your watch list
should have
a minimum, really, of two and a half times
the amount of ideas as versus real trades
or real
positions in your portfolio.
So, you should use that as a ratio.
So, whatever the size of your portfolio in
terms of positions, your watch list should
really have a minimum of two and a half
times
that in the amount of ideas that you have
on your watch list.
So, that's the first thing.
Now, let's go through the spreadsheets a
little bit and start breaking things down.
And we'll come on to some other concepts
when we look at a live example.
So, the example that we're going to look
at here is EasyJet, IAG, this idea that's
on the watch list here.
And EasyJet and IAG, they both trade in
the United Kingdom on the London Stock
Exchange.
And EasyJet is a low-cost airline carrier.
And IAG is a global airline carrier,
primarily Europe and Transatlantic, but
it's a global carrier.
And IAG is basically British Airways and
Iberia.
And IAG, International Consolidated
Airlines Group, is the holding company for
those two brands, for those two companies.
So, we're looking at the idea here on the
watch list of long EasyJet, short IAG.
And the long entry and the short entry of
this idea gives a spread of 438 on the
watch list.
And we haven't actually entered this
position.
What this is, is a reference price.
So, we're referencing the time, the price
of these stocks at the time that we put
them on the watch list.
And this gives us a reference spread of
438.
So, when we scroll across from here, we
have this repeated again here.
But we also have the current situation.
And the current situation, this is what
you update every week.
So, the current situation gives EasyJet at
10.31.
And IAG, International Consolidated
Airlines Group, at 258 spot 9.
And when we scroll across here, this gives
us a spread of 398.
Which means, overall, this spread from the
reference price, when it originally went
on the watch list, is down 9%.
And it's been on the watch list for 7
weeks.
And this is the second concept that you
have to pick up here.
So, concept number one, the amount of
trades that you need, or the amount of
ideas that you need on your watch list to
service your portfolio backed out.
So, spoiling yourself with a good amount
of ideas that become good trades.
So, don't forget that concept.
The concept that we're moving on to now is
really the primary reason why we have a
gatekeeping process and why we run a watch
list.
And that's really because we want to make
sure that we don't put on bad trades with
our real money.
But also, we want to make sure that we're
not mistiming good trades.
So, we're back to this example, again, of
buying an asset at, say, $100 or a stock
at $100.
And then, at this stage, it's an idea.
And what you have to assume is that
everybody in the world thinks when they
have an idea for a trade, that it's a
fantastic idea.
Otherwise, you wouldn't consider
committing capital to it.
So, just assume that every idea you get,
you're obviously going to think that it's
a great idea.
You know, we're all only human.
People think that all the time.
Of course, they do.
But that's the typical retail trader
mistake.
The typical retail trader mistake is to
get an idea and then just put the trade on
straight away.
Well, the professional trader realises
that they're only human and they have a
gatekeeping process to make sure that they
don't do anything stupid.
So, imagine if you buy, you think you have
this great idea and you buy this stock at
$100 and you think that a good stop loss
is $90.
And then, you just put the trade on
straight away at $100.
Well, at that stage, it's just an idea.
So, you put the trade on at $100 and then
you get stopped out at $90 and then it
goes to $500.
Well, that's the cardinal sin in trading.
What you've actually just done is you've
put on an idea and an idea at that stage
is just an idea.
It's not a trade.
And you put this idea on straight away,
you get stopped out, so you lose money,
but then you'll prove to be right.
What you could have done was just put the
trade on the watch list and then waited
for that idea to actually start working
before you committed capital.
Instead, you committed capital straight
away and you just got stopped out and then
you missed the opportunity to make $400 on
the upside.
Now, think of it in the opposite
situation.
You've got this idea and you put it on
straight away at $100.
You get stopped out at $90 and then it
goes to $0.
Well, that's just proven to be a bad idea
and a bad trade, but you've just lost 10%
and you could have avoided losing that 10%
by just sticking it on a watch list and
monitoring the price action and never
committing capital to a trade that wasn't
working.
So, you would have saved yourself 10%.
This is why we have a gatekeeping process
to stop ourselves mistiming potentially
good trades and to stop ourselves getting
into bad trades full stop.
Period.
So, you have to have this gatekeeping
process and make sure that you go through
it each week and spoil yourself with
enough ideas that they become, or a good
portion of them become, good trades.
And don't forget, everything that ends up
on your watch list is an idea that ticks
all the boxes in terms of agreeing with
your fundamental views of the world, the
industry view and the stock view.
So, by the time it ends up on the watch
list, it's in full fundamental agreement
with your views.
And then, what you're trying to do is
cleanse your idea and you're trying to add
value to your idea by putting it on a
watch list and monitoring the price action
and technicals.
So, you're trying to add value to the idea
and get into the idea when the price
action is good and the technicals are
good.
Now, this example here, EasyJet IAG.
This has lost 9% on the watch list over
seven weeks.
So, imagine if this trader just put this
idea on straight away, they'd be losing
9%.
That's not to say this trade isn't a good
trade.
It could actually be a phenomenal trade.
But what we're trying to do here is we're
trying to make sure that we get in at a
good price and we're trying to make sure
that we just don't enter a trade that's
bad full stop.
So, let's have a look at the breakdown of
these seven weeks.
And what we can see by scrolling across is
that the price action is pretty choppy.
And week six, this is where pretty much
all of the underperformance has come from.
And when we look at the price action in
absolute terms, it's not working.
This trade is not working.
So, we shouldn't be committing capital to
this trade.
Now, when we look at all the rest of our
trades, what are we looking at?
Well, we're looking at a bunch of ideas
that are working and a bunch of ideas that
are not working.
Well, the two back-of-the-envelope rules,
if you like.
You know, there are no rules in terms of
committing capital.
That's the third concept we're going to
come on to in a minute.
So, the two kind of back-of-the-envelope
rules of thumb when committing capital and
considering price action is that, firstly,
you shouldn't commit capital to losing
trades or losing ideas.
That's the first thing.
Secondly, what you're looking for is
consistency in price action, so
consistently positive returns.
And if we look further down here, we can
see potential trades, so ideas.
We've got ideas here that could be
potential trades where the price action is
positive and the weekly return.
Looks fairly consistent.
So, this one, SWFT, long and short, cat.
And also, HTZ and cat.
Positive and fairly consistent price
action.
So, we're not going to go into every
single idea on this watch list.
You can do that in your own time because
you've got the spreadsheet in the
downloads area.
But, just know the concepts here.
So, you understand that you don't commit
capital to positions or ideas that are
losing.
And you don't commit capital to losing
trades or losing ideas that have choppy
price action.
What you're looking for is the opposite.
You're looking for positive price action.
And you're looking for consistency in
returns.
If you do that over your lifetime, this
will not only save you a lot of money in
the gatekeeping process, but it will also
make you quite a lot of money as well.
Because you're cleansing and adding value
to every idea that you've got.
And that can only be a good thing.
So, what we're going to do now, now we've
picked up on those three concepts.
So, we'll just run through those again.
Enough ideas that turn into good trades.
So, a proportion of those trades will turn
into good trades.
Enough ideas to service your portfolio.
That's the first thing.
Secondly, most important one, the reasons
why we have a gatekeeping process.
To stop ourselves mistiming potentially
good ideas and to stop ourselves putting
on bad trades, full stop, period.
Three, committing capital.
And again, there's no rule book here.
We'll come back to this in a second.
There's no rule book for committing
capital, but a back of the envelope rule
of thumb.
Don't commit capital to trades or ideas
that are not working on your watch list
and have choppy price action.
You want the opposite, positive price
action with consistency or showing
consistency in returns.
So, they're the three concepts that you
need to get used to straight away.
Now, the process we're going to go through
now is I'm going to simulate a process of
updating your watch list.
Now, what you'll notice is all of these
trades here, all of these ideas, are
actually within, if we go to the bottom of
the sheet, the spreadsheet, are actually
within their own individual sheets.
So, what we're going to look at here is
EasyJet IAG again, as an example.
So, we're going to click in to this sheet.
And we can see that EasyJet International
Consolidated Airlines Group has its own
sheet.
And within that sheet, we've got the data
of both stocks and the spread.
We've got the daily data.
And if we scroll down on the sheet, this
daily data goes all the way back to 2003.
And we've got the charts as well.
And we've got the chart, which goes right
back to the beginning of the spread.
So, as far back as the data goes.
And we've got a zoomed-in chart for the
last two years.
And we're going to go through the process
now that you go through every week when
you're running your watch list, updating
it, and maintaining it.
So, you have to do this.
What I'm going to show you now, you have
to do this for every one of your spreads.
Don't worry about it too much.
Once you get used to the processes, it
becomes second nature.
And you end up doing this on a weekly
basis within just a couple of hours.
And it adds a lot of value to your life
and adds a lot of value to you as a
trader.
Because it saves you a lot of money and
also makes you a lot of money.
So, first thing we're going to do, we're
going to simulate this idea that it's the
end of the week.
And you're now updating your watch list.
And we're going to count five lines.
And we're going to insert five new rows
into the data area.
And what we're going to do now is go
online and we're going to get the EasyJet
and IAG data, work out the spread, and
update the whole watch list.
So, let's go online and let's go to Yahoo
Finance.
We'll click into there.
And what we're going to get now is we're
just going to get the EasyJet data.
So, we click into EasyJet and we go into
the historical prices.
And we've got the daily data here.
And the data that we want to get is
actually from the 25th of March up to and
including the 29th of March.
We want these five days here.
So, we're basically simulating that it's
Saturday, April the 1st, 2013.
And you're sitting at your desk at home in
the office, wherever you like to do this.
And you're updating your watch list.
So, let's get this data.
We scroll down.
We click on Download to Spreadsheet.
And we just open up the spreadsheet with
the data.
As I'm doing this video, by the way, it's
April 13th.
So, the last day is April the 12th.
So, we're just going to get rid of all of
this data here.
Because what we want is the 25th to the
29th.
So, this is the data we want.
And if it's Saturday, April the 1st, this
is what you're going to see when you
download this data.
And actually, on this day in the UK, on
Friday the 29th, it was a bank holiday.
We had the same close as we did the day
before and no volume traded.
But this was a Friday.
First thing we're going to do is actually
just copy that data.
And we're going to go back into the sheet
and insert the dates here.
And we'll go back to the EasyJet data and
take the adjusted close, including
dividends.
And we go back into EasyJet and insert
that.
Now, we need the IAG data.
So, we just go through the same process.
Download this into Spreadsheet.
International Consolidated Airlines Group.
So, make sure that we have the right dates
here.
We've got 25th to the 29th.
And we just take these prices here.
Insert them.
And then, when we're updating our spread,
we just autofill up by clicking on the box
here and autofill and by dragging up.
So, you can see here the spread last week.
So, we're still simulating here that it's
Saturday, April 1st, 2013.
So, the spread a week ago closed at
398.22.
And now, the spread is at 4.26.5.
So, the spread has basically gone up about
6%, which is good news because that means
positive price action.
So, we'll update this sheet in a minute.
But first, we're just going to update the
charts.
So, now, we click on the charts.
And what you'll see when you click on
Select Data is that we only have up to row
8 from row 8 selected.
So, we have to select row 3 to update the
charts.
So, we click on the series, edit, and
you'll see here D8.
We just need to change that to a 3.
And we do that again for the dates on the
horizontal axis.
We update that.
And here, you can see the spread's updated
with its positive price action.
Just get rid of that key.
We do the same on the chart below.
Right mouse, select data, edit.
Change D8 to D3 for both the vertical and
the horizontal axis.
And we can see it's updated there.
So, now, we're going to go back to the
main sheet here, our top sheet, the main
watch list sheet, where we're monitoring
price action.
And we're going to update week number 8
because that's the data that we've just
pulled off Yahoo Finance.
The data we pulled was for week 8.
And you'll see when you look at the
formula bar that the formula is S7 minus
the sum of U7 to AA7, which is basically
S7, this cell here, the total return of
the spread, minus the sum of the seven
weeks up to this point.
Now, just as a quick side note, this
formula is currently in this cell because
I've dragged it across already.
In week 7, this formula was in the week 7
cell.
And what I've done now is dragged it
across.
So, you have to do that yourself.
Make sure you drag it across before you do
the next step.
The next step is to actually hard code the
cell for week 7 to ensure that week 8
becomes a live cell.
So, then you just type over last week's
performance.
So, last week's performance was 1%.
So, we're going to type over it 1%.
And that gets rid of the formula.
And now, we have the formula in week 8 in
this cell.
And you can see now the contents of the
cell have lit up.
So, the cells become live.
So, now, what we do is we put our updated
prices into the current columns.
And this will then update week number 8.
So, let's go back to the sheet.
Our prices were 10.80 and 2.53 spot 2.
So, we type in 10.80 and 2.53 spot 2.
And these are pounds, by the way.
So, EasyJet and IAG, given that they trade
on the London Stock Exchange,
they're both currency denominated in
pounds.
So, this is 10.80 and this is 2.53.
You'll see the spread has updated to 4.27.
And the performance in week 8 was 6.5%.
So, that's worked out correctly because we
know it went from 3.98 to 4.26.5.
And this here is just a rounded up to two
decimal places number.
So, the total spread is down 2.5%.
So, it's still not working.
Since it's gone on the watch list.
And it has still choppy price action.
But it's managed in the last two weeks to
get back what it lost pretty much in week
6.
So, we're still keeping an eye on this
one.
And we're not committing capital yet,
probably.
But we're just going to go through now the
idea or the process logic of how you would
commit capital to a potential trade.
So, we're going to use this as an example.
But the main concept to get out of this
part of the video that we've just gone
through is the process that you go through
in terms of updating your watch list.
So, updating the last five days, updating
your top sheet and inferring the price
action.
And now we're moving on to how you would
actually go and commit capital.
Also, we're going to change this cell to
week 8.
So, don't forget those processes.
You have to do this for every spread
trade.
You know, you have to do this as well.
For example, for Hewlett-Packard, Cisco,
if that was one of your ideas, you just do
the same thing.
Select five rows.
Insert.
Get the data.
Update the charts.
Right mouse, select data.
Go through the processes.
This is going to save you and make you a
lot of money over your lifetime.
It's well worth doing.
And once you're used to it, it only takes
you a few hours every week.
You know, I tend to do this on a Saturday
morning for a couple of hours.
And what you do is, when you've updated
these processes, you know, you've got a
bunch of ideas here.
And if you have enough high-quality ideas
on your watch list, all that's going to
happen is that your watch list is going to
start servicing your portfolio.
Because good trades are going to present
themselves to you.
So good ideas are going to turn into good
trades.
And they're going to end up in your
portfolio.
So what you're going to see week to week
is trades will present themselves to you.
They'll pop their head up and wave their
hand and say,
Hello, Mr. Trader, I'm now working.
I'm one of your ideas and I'm now working.
And that's usually a positive sign to
start committing capital.
So make sure you've got enough ideas.
Make sure you remember the concepts that
we went through at the beginning of the
video.
And go through these processes every week.
Now, moving on to capital commitment.
And this might be a little bit difficult
to get your head around.
But, unfortunately, you cannot go down to
the local bookstore.
You cannot go on Amazon.com and buy a book
called, In All Situations, This Is How You
Deploy Capital.
Because it just doesn't exist.
Every retail trader looks for a rule book.
Every professional trader knows there
isn't one.
Because in terms of committing capital,
you have to take every trade on its own
individual merits.
So let's take this EasyJet IAG example on
its individual merits.
And we already know at this stage that
from the reference prices, when we put it
on the watch list,
that the price action is not positive to
this point.
And the technicals, when we look at them,
are not exactly great.
So, we're kind of here nor there.
When we look at the technicals, we're in
what we'd call an amber situation.
We're kind of range trading here.
So, this is the last two years.
What we can do is take a line, just to
illustrate this a little bit better.
So, let's just make this red and increase
its thickness a little bit.
Give us a better representation of what
this is actually doing.
So, we've got negative price action
overall, since it was referenced onto the
watch list.
And we've got choppy price action, so
overall price action is not great.
We're now looking at the technicals, and
the technicals really are giving us an
amber situation.
It doesn't take long to deduce these
things.
So, we're kind of in this range here.
And when we look at the overall
technicals, you know, they look good.
So, we've got a two-year chart here, where
over the last two years, we've got a
really strong positive trend, and now
we're trending sideways in a range.
And overall, we've got a very good
positive trend as well.
So, the overall picture looks good here.
And what we're trying to do here is work
out when we should commit capital at the
right time.
Well, we've got this nice support level
here.
We've got this resistance level.
And we're kind of here nor there.
We look like we're in a short-term range.
If we look at the last two years, you
know, this is a big move.
You know, do we really want to be the fool
that buys this spread right at the top?
You know, we want to see positive price
action here.
We want to be proved correct that this is
going to continue to go higher.
So, what I'm going to do first, a couple
of logical things, is work out what this
resistance level is here.
So, let's have a look.
This is at some point in February, so
towards the beginning of 2013.
And if we go through the data on the
left-hand side, we can see, actually, that
this 453.84
seems to be the trading high of the
spread.
So, that's our resistance level, 453.84.
And now, if you were feeling brave, what
you could do here, and this is always an
option.
So, the first option is non-participation.
That's always an option.
The second option is to commit all your
capital, which in this situation, in an
amber technical
situation with not positive price action,
is probably a bit stupid.
You might as well not have the watch list
at all, or the gatekeeping process at all,
if you commit
all your capital here.
But option number three is to commit some
capital.
So, I would say, if you were feeling
brave, you could actually go in and maybe
take what
we call a starter position.
So, you start with something.
So, let's say, for example, you thought
your full position size was going to be
longer
$10,000 of EasyJet, short $10,000 of IAG.
Well, in this situation, if you're feeling
brave, what you could do is go and deploy
$5,000 on
each side, so you put half a position on.
And if you put half a position on in these
situations, it gives you choices.
It gives you some choices.
So, let's say, for example, we know this
is at 427.
Let's say we put this spread on at 427.
Well, what would a 10% stop loss be?
So, let's work this out.
We just multiply that by 0.9.
So, 427 times 0.9 is 384.
So, let's change the colour of this line
to green.
And we'll call this our theoretical stop
loss.
So, this would be at 384.
So, around here.
So, we've got this nice support level at
400 or 4.
We've got a theoretical stop loss at 384.
But that stop loss is on a full position.
So, a 10% stop loss on a full position is
fairly sensible.
It's wide enough to give us a chance of
making money over 1 to 3 months.
You'd obviously go and double-check that
with the ATR.
And we'll do that in subsequent videos.
But this is on a full position.
So, what would happen if you had a starter
position?
Well, the first choice it would give you
is that you could actually widen your stop
loss.
So, if you put on half a position, you can
double the stop loss.
So, we can take 427 and multiply that by
0.8 to give it a 20% stop loss, which
gives you a stop loss of 341.
Here.
And that gives you choices.
You know, you could also, for example, if
this fell off a cliff in the future and
got to this level,
you know, you could actually, if it
started showing positive price action
again,
go and purchase the other 50% and end up
with your stop loss 10% below your average
price.
So, that gives us our first choice.
The second choice it also gives us is that
if it continues showing positive price
action
and goes through this resistance level of
453.84,
then we could actually go and buy the
other half of the position
if it's showing and agreeing with our view
and breaking to new highs.
And you would end up with an average price
below the resistance level,
which could become the new support.
And your stop loss would be well below
your average price if you put a 10% stop
loss on it.
So, a starter position does give you
choices.
But, as I said, that's, you know, if
you're feeling brave.
And there's, again, no rules here to
committing capital.
Unfortunately, you can't buy that book off
Amazon.com.
How to commit capital to all trading
situations.
There are no rules.
You have to just use your common sense.
You know, the best thing you can do as a
trader
is to generate as many high-quality ideas
as you can
and then have a gatekeeping process
and try to time ideas.
So, good ideas that end up becoming good
trades
and try to not commit capital to bad
trades.
So, you have that gatekeeping process in
place
and try to spoil yourself
by having as many good ideas as possible
that turn into good trades
and then deploy capital using common
sense.
So, this resistance level here
of 453, I think it was,
on the 7th, yep, 453.84,
if it trades through there,
you know, this could be a situation
where you start adding to a winning trade.
And we're going to look at this concept a
bit further
when we go into the psychology part
of the video series.
So, don't worry about this too much.
You should pick up this concept
of winning and losing trades
or winning and losing ideas
when we get into this trading psychology
stage.
So, you might want to watch this video
back again
once you've seen those modules
so you get a better appreciation
and understanding of what we're looking at
here.
But this resistance level of 453,
let's introduce this idea of
winning and losing trades.
So, if we had a stop loss on a,
let's say we put a full position on here.
Let's just assume that we put a full
position on
and we were feeling super brave and super
silly
and we put a full position on
at 4.27, where we're trading at now.
And our stop loss was 3.84.
So, that's 4.27 multiplied by 0.9.
That gives us a 10% stop loss.
So, 4.27 times 0.9 gives 3.84 as a stop
loss.
But, when we're working out our target
on a 1 to 3 ratio,
we call our target a soft target.
And this will all become clear in later
videos,
so don't worry.
So, we offer more on our upside than our
downside on every trade.
And we have to look at our targets as soft
targets.
With those soft targets, we need to see
that they are realistic targets.
So, we have what we call hard stop losses,
where no matter what, if the spread
actually trades there,
we trade out.
And if it reaches our target, we run the
trade and we may even actually add to the
position.
And then move our stop loss up above our
average price so we still make money.
So, in this situation, if we minus 384
from 4.27,
we get 43 points on this trade.
So, our stop loss is a loss of 43 points.
If we multiply that by 3,
we get 129 points.
And that's our soft target,
129 points added on to 4.27,
which is 5.56.
Now, when we look at the entire history of
this spread,
it's never ever traded at 5.56.
So, is it realistic to have
a target,
a soft target of 5.56?
Think about this for a second.
Is it realistic?
Well, I'm guessing that most of you are
probably saying no.
But, in fact,
it's arguably just as realistic as it is
unrealistic.
So,
you would say it's unrealistic
because it's never traded there.
But if you look at the history of the
spread,
imagine if you were here
in this period
and you said,
I'm not going to put this spread on
because if I put this spread on
on a 1 to 3 ratio
with a 10% stop loss,
my target would have to be roughly 70
points
from this level.
So,
that would imply
a target of 340,
350 points
and it's never traded there.
It's never traded above 3.
That would have been the high
if we were looking at it
at this point in time.
And you wouldn't have put it on
and you'd have missed all of this upside.
See,
this is the point.
It's arguably
as realistic
as unrealistic
because this spread
could just go to infinity,
theoretically.
it could just go up forever.
And if you,
when we're looking at spread trades,
this is why we have
the stock
that we want to go long
on the top
of the fraction
and the stock
that we want to go short
on the bottom of the fraction
because
that means in all cases
we're looking
at going long
the chart.
We're looking at
going long
the spread.
And
that's the phrase
that we use.
We're going long
the spread.
And theoretically
it could go to infinity.
So
in this situation,
you know,
when you're looking
at examples
where
you're looking
at a spread
that has
never traded
at a certain target,
well,
it's arguably
just as realistic
as unrealistic.
because what you're
looking at here
is a spread
that's,
you know,
at or near
all-time highs.
And for the last
two years
it's just been
putting in
new all-time highs.
Well,
for at least
the last 18 months.
And that price action
is incredibly positive
and it could just continue.
So
when we think
about this
example overall,
we've got
short-term
negative price action
in overall terms
and in consistency.
We've got
an overall
positive picture
in terms of
medium
and long-term
price action.
and in terms
of committing capital,
in terms of
technical,
sorry,
in terms of
technicals,
we're on an amber.
We're looking at
range trading
at the moment
and when we add
all of this up,
just using common sense,
in terms of
committing capital,
we're probably
going to have to be
brave to put
a starter position on
but we can always
add
or
increase the
position
if we see
this spread
come off
and we get
a lower price.
That would be
fantastic if we
got a lower price
and then we had
positive price action.
But it would also
be equally
fantastic if it
just broke out
and we got a
full position on
somewhere at
these prices
and it broke
resistance
and
EasyJet
because that's
probably where
the performance
is going to
come from.
EasyJet
is going to
break out
on its
individual chart
and start
trading
high volume.
That would
confirm
in terms of
technical signals
would confirm
very positive
price action
and technicals.
So we're just
trying to use
some common sense
here in
deploying our
capital
and it
will save
us a lot
of money
and make
us a lot
of money
over our
lives.
So again
there's no
rule book
here so
don't worry
about it.
You've just
got to learn
from experience
in terms of
capital deployment
and go through
the processes
the checklist.
We're not
going to go
through every
example.
You've just
got to learn
how to do
this by using
common sense.
if you see
negative price
action
overall
choppy price
action week
to week
negative
technicals
and it
doesn't
it's starting
to not match
your fundamental
predisposition
you'd obviously
be a fool
to commit
capital.
This is why
we have all
these processes
in place.
This is what
professional
traders do.
Retail
traders
unfortunately
don't have
these processes
and this is
one of the
main reasons
why they
lose money
all the
time.
So let's
have a quick
recap.
Back to the
watch list.
Enough
ideas on
your watch
list to
service your
portfolio.
The reason
why we have
on a
gatekeeping
process.
Make sure
you understand
those concepts.
The processes
that we go
through
every week.
Make sure
you go
through them.
Inferring
the price
action
as negative
or positive
and choppy
or consistent.
Are the
technicals
good,
ugly
or nowhere
or neither
here nor
there.
So red,
green or
amber.
If everything
matches up
to your
fundamental
predisposition,
then you'll
be committing
capital.
Don't be
scared of it.
If it doesn't
match up at
all, do not
commit capital.
That would
just be silly.
And if it's
neither here nor
there, if
you're feeling
brave, you
can commit
some capital
if you're
feeling brave.
But be
under no
illusion, you
just need to
know what
you're doing
so you
can deploy
capital.
Overall, in
terms of capital
deployment, there
is no rulebook.
You just have
to use your
common sense.
Okay, so that
pretty much
concludes the
watch list
example.
You can get
these sheets
in the
download section.
Make sure you
go through those
processes every
week.
Like I said,
once you have
done this for
a couple of
weeks, it
becomes second
nature.
So just get
used to it.
Don't worry
too much about
it for now.
You'll learn a
lot more about
some of the
concepts that we
looked at in
this video in
subsequent
videos, so you
might want to
come back and
watch this
video again.
Okay, so let's
move on and
I'll see you in
the next video.
Okay, welcome
back.
So let's
summarise price
action and
technical analysis
and let's
summarise the
entire gatekeeping
process and how
we view it and
how we should
use it.
Now, we
looked at TA
and we realised
that technical
analysis is one
tool that we
can use in
order to add
value to our
already generated
ideas.
so we can
end up
generating a
potentially good
trade and
avoiding bad
trades.
And that's
exactly how we
use price action
as well when
we're monitoring
our price action
on our watch
list on a week
to week basis.
And you can see
also that from
the watch list
spreadsheet, we
also include all
of our spread
charts and our
technical analysis
within the same
spreadsheet.
and it's very
straightforward.
You know, every
week you can do
this on a
Saturday morning
where you just
take the last
five days of
data in stocks,
in commodities,
in currencies,
for the spreads
and work out the
spreads and just
monitor the price
action.
And obviously
you don't want to
be committing
capital to trades
that are not
working and
missing out on
trades that
are showing
good, consistent
returns and
price action on
a week to week
basis combined
with very good
technicals.
So, you know,
what ends up on
your watch list
is obviously
ideas that you
think are good
ideas.
So you want to
commit capital
to those ideas
that are working
technically well
and the price
action is good
and is showing
consistency.
So don't be
afraid of that.
You commit capital
to these trades
and when these
trades actually
become real
trades, they
end up in your
portfolio and
they are real
positions.
Now, when you
are running a
portfolio, let's
work backwards
and try to
work out what
we should really
be doing here
on our watch
list.
When you're
running a
portfolio and
you're, for
example, running
a portfolio of
say, with
exposure, with
$100,000, if
your position
limits are
10% and
we're going to
move on to
risk management
soon and
you'll realise
what we mean
by position
limits, if
your restriction
that you've
given yourself
in your
portfolio is
for a
single position
to be no
bigger than
10% of your
portfolio, so
with your
exposure being
$100,000 and
your position
limit being
$10,000, if
that's the
scenario, you're
going to have
10 positions
when you're
fully invested.
Now, when we
back this out, it's
pretty obvious that
you can't just
have 10
ideas.
You're going to
have to have
at least two
and a half
times the
amount of
ideas on
your watch
list as you
do for real
positions in
your portfolio.
So, this is
what we mean
when we look
at a
conveyor belt
of ideas.
So, every
week, you're
not just
monitoring your
own portfolio,
your live
portfolio, you're
also generating
more ideas to
replace ideas
that aren't
working on
your watch
list.
So, you have
your portfolio,
you have your
watch list, and
you have more
idea generation
on top.
And your
watch list has
ideas that are
working and are
not working on
it.
And in your
portfolio, you
have trades that
are working and
not working.
Now, trades that
are working on
your portfolio, you
keep them in your
portfolio.
Trades that are
not working, you
are probably
looking at some
point to replace
them with ideas
from the watch
list that are
now becoming
good trades.
And the
trades or ideas
on your watch
list which are
not working, over
time, you're
going to be
replacing with
fresh and new
ideas to keep
your watch list
up to date and
to keep your
watch list
current.
And these are
the processes
that you have to
go through every
week.
So, at any
one point in
time, you will
have your live
portfolio and
you'll have your
watch list.
The two things
that you have to
do each week
is to update
your watch list
which includes
updating all the
statistics but
also refreshing
new ideas onto
your watch list
and getting rid
of old and
stale ideas
but also
replacing losing
trades in your
portfolio with
ideas that are
now becoming
good trades
that are showing
good technical
analysis, good
price action and
good consistent
returns on a
week to week
basis.
These are the
things that you
have to do.
So, if you have
10 positions, you
can't have 10
ideas.
You have to have
at least 25 on
your watch list.
So, just use that
as a rule of
thumb.
The rule of
thumb is whatever
the amount of
trades or positions
you have in your
portfolio, back
that out and have
at least two and
a half times the
amount of ideas on
your watch list that
you're monitoring on
a week to week
basis.
So, what happens
next?
Well, you've got a
live portfolio and
when you've got a
live portfolio, you
need risk management.
You need to have
discipline.
But, to have
discipline, you need
to have the right
psychology.
So, let's move to
the next video.
Video number 22.
We're going to go
and have a look at
trading psychology
now and you're
going to find this
a little bit
entertaining and
you're going to
find it surprising.
But, take it
seriously because the
messages are very,
very,
serious and very,
very straightforward.
But, if you don't
get them, you can
lose a lot of
money.
You need to have
the right psychology
before you actually
have real positions
in your portfolio.
So, let's go over
to video number 22
and I'll see you
on the other side.